ciel bleu et grand soleil sur la côte de
la mer noire mais en plein mois d'août
les plages sont désertes les rares
touristes ont dû troquer le sable fin
pour bronzer à même la corniche cet été
là mais rossi est une zone de guerre
celui-ci comme vous pouvez le voir il
n'y a personne sur les plages elles sont
fermées plus personne ne peut y accéder
en temps normal pendant l'été notre
hôtel accueille environ 400 personnes
mais là on n'a pas plus de sens
vacanciers voire moins avant on avait
beaucoup de clients d'arabie saoudite de
l'union européenne de turquie et
d'israël mais maintenant on a plus que
des touristes locaux
c'est très difficile même le
delphinarium l'attraction la plus
populaire de la ville ne parvient pas à
afficher complet
habituellement sur les 850 sièges
disponibles pas un seul n'est vide mais
vous avez vu aujourd'hui il n'y avait
pas plus de cinquante visiteurs
quelques touristes venus d'autres
régions ukrainienne pour retrouver un
semblant de normalité loin du chaos
nous sommes venus ici pour fuir un peu
les explosions de micola fc terrible là
bas les enfants peur ici au moins ils
peuvent mieux dormir imaginez ce que
c'est quand les murs tremblent et que du
plâtre leur tombe dessus depuis le
plafond on est venu pour eux
ici c'est calme la vie est complètement
différente de celle de nicolas yves
c'est vraiment très bizarre pour nous de
se dire que des choses horribles se
passe pas si loin d'ici
les rares touristes qui sont en vacances
à odessa doivent se contenter de ces
piscines dans les nombreux hôtels et
resorts qui longe le littoral de la mer
noire à défaut de pouvoir se baigner
dans celle ci interdite depuis que les
ukrainiens y ont déposé des mines pour
exclure la possibilité d'une attaque des
russes par la mer et bien cela n'empêche
pas certains baigneurs de jouer au chat
et à la souris avec les autorités selon
la police ukrainienne cela a coûté la
vie à un baigneur ukrainien au début de
l'été mort dans une explosion de l'une
de ces mines